nein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft game 5 wer die
letzte folge nicht gesehen hat er
definitiv aus verpasst hier wird die
ganze zeit amrum rating gelesen es war
unglaublich ich bin teilweise ich habe
einmal die kopfhörer abgerissen bin
meinem zimmer umgelaufen einmal
geschrieben weil wir die geile sprünge
nicht geschafft haben wir sind ich habe
eine etage höher und es geht genauso
weiter wir sind immer noch komplette
pros und warum nicht den teppich warum
sie dann lebt teppich liegt ganz einfach
aus dem grund weil ich mal wieder so
großzügig waren mir gedacht habe kommen
spendiert den damit ihr aufnahmen wie
schöner wirkt ihr damit diese den sprung
hier nicht mal ist auch echt gemeint der
ist echt richtig böse auch meine ich
weiß auch hier kommen so in meiner folge
an bei dem spruch du auf anhieb
geschafft
ich helfe dir lass es sein dass es eine
bitte kommen kommentiert man dass es
sein dass es sein lasst es sein comeback
kommen
das ist ja komme ja mal irgendwann auch
deshalb wollte diesen sprung war ich dir
dann irgendwas doch noch ja stimmen da
bestimmt irgendwie wette war das ja
kaufen die lamborghini am besten ist als
jeder deshalb etwas cooles war dass das
war ich nicht ich auch einfach darüber
hinaus ist doch nicht wahr leute welche
tipps hatte springen dann geht mir zum
beispiel sagt sie ja mit dem mit dem
effekt er aktiviert ihr mit aktiviert
ihr ein
den kombi nur mit der taste aktiviert
ihr einen magnet modus dass wir dann uns
mit den blöcken irgendwie magnetisierten
kennen dann naja das super nett er ist
recht einfach ganz entspannt um die ecke
gehen du musst einfach alles entspannt
gesehen weil ich immer komplett
abgeschafft ich auch jetzt nicht mehr so
entspannt nicht irgendwie so verkrampft
ganz spielt es los springt dann haben
uns nicht wahr sein
ich frag mal nebenbei auf twitter nach
themen für die scheiben das könnte
machen das wollten wir ja meine letzte
angekündigt dass wir über eure themen
quatschen wollten ich mache jetzt mal
ganz locker wie kommen das meinte ja
geil läuft ich sage nicht mehr normal
hier so eure trittin für konnte für game
ja hier konzentriere ich mich mal muss
ich denn jetzt hin
man kann mich eine lange docht nicht
doch ich war schon viel weiter
ich hab mir blocken ich hab' ich habe
mein blog über mir dann ja genau die
muss sprinten und ganz spät erst ab
springen sprinten und dann später ist
los verdammt kopf zack zack zack zack
verdammt ich war schon weit aber den
turm der copa nach oben wie weit er noch
geht ist das ist unglaublich wie hoch
der ist das ist unmöglich
komme ich hab gerade dich abgeschossen
was also ich hab ja ich hab nämlich
geschossen aber ich habe schaden
bekommen so nach dem motto das nicht
getroffen wie boxen dich echt jetzt
das ist richtig komisch gewesen gerade
hell wie macht man das mit der leiter
ich bin da schon wieder reichlich luft
haben einfach runter weil ich gegen
mirko hier springe guck mich mal sprint
und ganz spät ja genau so geht das meine
lieben freunde ja genau ich hab's aber
herrschen geschafft ja auch geschafft
sehr schön ich schließlich mal nicht ab
ich möchte auch mal das werden wir nicht
weiter kommt ich schließe mich schon
selber ab das kann doch nicht sein dass
das ist so hoch geht noch kann ja sein
dass wir gleich gepostet werden
ich denke ich mir nochmal das ist echt
nicht mehr nummer hier das ohne spaß die
ganze piepmätze da dachte schon wir
wären scheiße und so richtig richtige
geboten einfach aber jetzt dagegen die
sprünge ja noch man aber wir sind ja
auch in hat das muss man sagen ja der
ist auch alles hart deswegen ist jetzt
halt kein zuckerschlecken
das leben ist kein ponyhof in ihren
erinnerungen genau wir müssen und hier
ganz normal und ich schaffe das gerade
wenig ab ich fühle ich mich wieder so
eine ruhe hier so also hier der lukas
guck mal jahren läuft broich
fragezeichen
jetzt gerade beläuft bei mir schon ich
bin schon hinter dieser ich bin so weit
war ich noch nie nein
ich hab nicht mal dort tobt auch man
kann doch nicht sein weiß auch wenn du
dann diese erfolgserlebnisse heißt ja
ich hab's ein stück weiter geschafft
dann ist wieder alles so kommt wie weit
so weit wollte der lukas hat nur
geschrieben ob und bei uns läuft genau
leute wenn ihr genau gerade dann online
seid wenn wir themen wollen brauchen sie
noch ihr habt noch gar nicht nach
geguckt was das kostet dann fühlt sich
doch als zuschauer nicht schreiben läuft
bei richter will ich doch irgendwas was
mich interessiert aber vielleicht
interessiert ihn dass er auch das sagen
weil interessierten das jeden abend
quält er sich im bett mit der frage
läuft wohl bei conny und komme kann
deswegen nicht einschlafen und alles
nein es ist eigentlich nicht so schwer
an nur diese anfangs sprung volk hat
schon wieder ein game hat einst genau
ich aber nicht gesagt ich schaffe das
jetzt erst wenn hier auch themen
vorgeschlagen die wir beide glaube ich
schon mal auch behandelt hat nämlich zum
beispiel wie steht ihr zu fanpages und
fan fiction stoffe das hatten wir schon
mal bei stellen das hat er wirklich
schon mal das hat jedenfalls
superkräften odernähe das war mit denen
man glaube ich nicht dass mit
superkräften mir auch dass ich die gerne
die kraft hätte die wartezeit anzuhalten
zurückzudrehen genau das thema hatten
wir schon mal dann und wild zu fanpages
falls diese person das short und die
eventuell die alte folge nicht gewinnen
haben wir buch zusammengefasst gesagt
wenn die fanpages verrückten arschloch
wenn die fanpage ist vernünftig sind es
ist in ordnung aber wenn da zum beispiel
steht offizielle fanpage oder so dann
als dass ihr offizielles und dann wenn
sich das nicht ist dann ist es halt ein
bisschen blöd und auch wenn man fotos
einfach cloud und bei sich auf dem
profil an in die hochlädt oder videos
einfach kopiert dann ist das ganze nicht
so schön wenn man natürlich eine fanpage
macht dann bilder aus von allem aus
videos davon da hochlädt oder irgendwie
sowas oder coole sprüche oder so dann
ist das in ordnung
als auch schön dass auch unsere meinung
dazu
ganz genau ins eigene arbeit ist es
super super duper ich darf das nicht so
locker angehen ich muss da irgendwie
weil sie nicht guck mal ich mal ein
anderer tod von crafter viel aus der
welt so weil ich das kabarett für uns
beide bitte bitte bitte ok nein ja da
bin ich auch von gestorben aber auch
gemeine sprünge die sind so gemein
vor allem bei mir ist es immer so immer
bei solchen sprüngen lag das auch so ein
bisschen finde ich also ich weiß nicht
ob das hab ich mir das nur einbildung
die beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt hier
zu springen ok jetzt gerade hatte ich
auch nicht weiß
es lag nicht richtig aber so
zwischendurch geht ruckelt den fünf
klein wenig dunkler ruhla
damit würden sonst so geschrieben das
kann eben gucken brachte musstet ihr
schon mal nachsitzen wenn ja wie lange
noch nie ja ich auch noch nicht musste
ehrlich gesagt dann ihn absetzen
bei uns muss man damals nach setzen wenn
man ihnen die fünf mal die hausaufgaben
vergessen hat in der unterstufe
ich hatte aber also pro halbjahr
ich hatte aber eigentlich immer das so
geregelt dass ich immer unter 5
geblieben bin weil ich wirklich übel ist
der respekt bei uns vom nachsitzen hatte
weil das bei der lehrerin war die keiner
so wirklich mochte
und das gibt's auch mittlerweile glaube
ich gar nicht mehr dieses nachsitzen war
noch so etwas wie strafarbeiten glaube
ich das ist ja auch nichts ganz neues
das musste ich was mir das muss die dame
da muss mir eine machen ich bin das mal
mit meinem physischen popo eine ein
geländer runtergerutscht eckig lass mal
ganz vorne mitfahren kann sich ein
geländer runtergerutscht
so kenne er mit dem sus leid mit dem po
auf der seite von dem gelände nein der
seite auf dem geländer und so was alles
unter kam lehrer anhöhe machst du das
zuhause auch und ich so ja eigentlich
schon
naja mir egal du schreibst du erst mal
eine seite wo mir dass sie tun sollte
dann habe ich halt wirklich so groß
geschrieben und ich habe ein kinder
reingepackt dass es mir leid tut dass
sie zu hause ja auch nicht machen würde
und so fand ich eigentlich gar nicht so
schlimm weil damals noch dies immer voll
wenn man die texte schreibt deswegen
mittlerweile mag ich das auch als ich
habe es auf dem deutschen glaube ich 24
seiten geschrieben und das geht ja noch
deswegen mag ich mag eigentlich so
schreiben das ist voll komisch was mir
heute auch wieder aufgefallen ist ich
mag es total wenn man wenn ich mich bei
leuten entschuldigen weil ich das vor
ich finde es toll schön wenn man was
heißt das hat sich voll komisch an im
ersten moment ich finde es schön wenn
man eben so alten leuten im weg steht
und dann sagen die entschuldigung und
dann wollen die sogar bei der theorie
entschuldigung tut mir leid und die sah
ja klar macht nix unser weiß nicht wie
wir das immer voll schön wenn die da
wenn man sich so entschuldigt und die
anderen leute akzeptieren das mag ich
irgendwie ja wenn ich darüber nachdenke
was wir also ich muss auch noch die
nachsitzen euro und einer strafarbeit
das so ist echt wegen sowas richtig
unnötigen eigentlich gewesen weil du
bist ja auch dass wenn ich das jetzt
erwähne alle was so ein quatsch oder das
war jetzt nicht schlimmer so dass wir im
winter da habe ich mal ein paar freunden
eine kleine schneeballschlacht gebracht
musste sein natürlich und da gab es
damals dann ganz dick ärger wenn der
staat den sand dann da da musste ich
dann auch irgendwie was war das
eigentlich auch eine seite oder zwei
seiten also darüber schreiben da wollte
natürlich damit gedroht wenn alles noch
mal passiert ja da müsst ihr natürlich
die schulordnung abschreiben die
eigentliche 20
doch immer gesagt ja nur eine seite und
wird auch immer so gesagt hat uns
bekommt den schulverweis also nun also
jetzt so richtig ich dachte so auf
nachsitzen beziehung zum unterricht sehr
das böse sachen gemacht du musst jetzt
eine stunde nach setzen oder aber so
könnt ihr auch noch sagen dass wir
damals als wir skifahren waren das war
als wir alle 15 waren da fing das so
gerade an dass man also mal mit bier
getrunken hat also so richtig knuffig
und einen freund von uns er hat halt
irgendwie direkt übertrieben und musste
dann irgendwie rückwärts essen und wir
alle muss man dafür bildeten und dürften
ganzen tag dann kein skifahren das war
eine bestrafung die ich auch noch in der
schulzeit erfahren hatte dann halt wenn
man wirklich mit handy im unterricht war
wo wir dann wo dann halt einfach das
handy ein gesagt wird dann war es bei
uns auch damals so wenn man scheiße
gesagt hat musste man kuchen mitbringen
nein ja doch die triste nötig
richtig dumm hatte da irgendwie so dicke
lehrerin dich ja ja keine ahnung sollte
so kleinere sachen halt das war aber nie
wirklich schlimm
weißt du das war dann mal am tag nicht
skifahrer das ist jetzt auch überleben
und auch und kuchen mitbringen sagt
sogar er schön weil wir haben immer
irgendwie so diese marmorkuchen zu hause
alle hart wie machen wir bestimmt kein
marmorkuchen natürlich wunder besser
kuchen
wir müssen jetzt ganz gut wieder hier
über das ding hier sprechen damit wir
uns konzentrieren er das kann ja nicht
sein aber ich hab immer noch drei
holzkohle im gegensatz zu dir ein
bisschen hängt schon wieder zwölf jahren
kannst dich einmal zu kippen da bist du
ganz schön weit schon mal ich bin hier
gerade bei
ja kann man hier wohl um die ecke ich
bin noch ein stück weit das habe ich
aber gerade gesehen ja ich hab mich
gerade game und gesetzt und wollte
eigentlich das hinsetzen aber ich komm
erstmal ich komme jetzt mal zu dir und
jetzt versuchen wir von hier
das ist jetzt unsere alles was wir uns
aussuchen dürfen
das ist aber dunkel hier findest du dich
an dicht machen
schön wie kann man denn die hoch
klettern um hier die sprünge gehen
vollkommen ohne zutaten komme ich hier
gerade durch hey wie kommt man an ihr
hoch ich komme da hoch ich bin runter
gefallen die komplette hofer den leitern
hoch zu leiden da muss also hoch kleiner
bewegung immer weiter nach rechts immer
ein stückchen aber du darfst nicht die
leiter ganz nach oben gehen
ich bin übrigens auch wieder runter
gefallen obwohl ich so weit war ja gut
dann mache ich jetzt mal ganz kurz hier
dass wir jetzt hier mal wenigstens ein
bisschen vorankommen ist erfreulich dass
hier mal etwa kommt sogar vorbei dann
ich mach das mal so ja dann das ist
eigentlich schon genug ich habe zwei
sachen verändert an dieser map hier
damit jetzt nicht alle mainzer bietet
voll doof
jetzt müsste es eigentlich noch mehr
machbar sein dass ich habe zum beispiel
einen blog mal weggeschlagen und zwei
leitern dazu gesetzt
wir schaffen wirtschaften geschaffen hat
jetzt kommen wir los wir müssen an uns
glauben
wie lange wir noch mal die letzte folge
bei dir warte warte wie war 90 minuten
lang ist romy reuille 1 19 minuten das
kam mir vor wie 27 oder so die lange
jetzt ein bisschen modifiziert
ja hättest du gar nicht machen müssen
die leiter kommst du auch so richer
nicht ach man das ist so ingo miß voll
gewisser da haben wir nach und nach
isoliert alles also rasiert die ganze
zeit und jetzt einfach bin ich hier
wieder sonne einstiegspunkt von goma hd
setzt auf blau ich habe neue
einstiegspunkt ich bin über dir jetzt
ich bin schon mal eine etage weiter als
das was bringt mir den sonnenschein
stieg ich nicht teil sogar mit den extra
leitern unter das ist doch nicht mehr
normal komme
du wirst auch hier shift drücken war das
schiff zurück wie soll ich musste hier
muss man den leitern shift drücken
ja klar aber wir sollen 100 ich gucke
mal nach rächt sich dass das hier immer
irgendwie alles zu minecraft seit
gestern oder bist einfach nur dumm
wir wollten sie doch oder software group
ist es auch hoffentlich bei ihrem haus
lobte es immer aus leiterwand oh das
wird sich aber freude wo ich gerade
bitten eltern nicht ohne spaß wir haben
uns so ausgemalt ja 5 spiele 5 part so
das war natürlich ihr berechnet das ist
ja ich dachte so viel spiele fünf
partien immer nur eine säule das sieht
nicht so viel aus wo bin ich gerade ich
bin in einem
das steht ja erzielte paar griffige
bands ig ist breiten bett weil der ist
somalia
ich bin den anderen ganz neuen
standpunkt serbisch weiter weit unten
bis vancouver nach oben wohl mein name
ist nein ich bin daten montag gefallen
ich guck mal ganz einer skizze ja nicht
einfach hin ich habe mir das auf jeden
fall holzkohle drin aber das ist das ist
das ist letzte tage gott bist ist das
die letzte tat ist das zehnmal so viel
wie jetzt einfach hierhin nein ich bin
runter gefallen 998 du warst schon so
weit okay jetzt habe ich außer sind ua
so geht das mit den sliden ja damit mit
einfach mit shift walter jetzt jetzt hat
es gerade gesehen mit dem lenker meine
lieben freunde und bei mir im video
hoffe ich mal alter ist der sprung
gemein ist der sprung im einsatz ich bin
bei einer glasröhre oh ja ich hab ich
hab echt so ein herz pochen kreise ob
ich bin oben schon mal ich bin sehr weit
oben
das nicht ruhe dass die tour die du in
mind ist kohle ich auch ein stück kohle
ja wohl keiner fixpunkt gesetzt da bist
du auch schon cool auch schon cool und
wurde durch ist porzellan aber das ist
ja schön dass dass wir die dings hier
schon haben denen dass ich den
einstiegspunkt gesessen habe mannomann
auf jeden fall was wird das was wir
gesagt das da drüben anscheinend ein
portal ist aber ich verstehe nicht was
sie damit meinen
irgendwie weiß ich gerade überhaupt
nicht weiter wo ich lange springen soll
aber ich werde den weg finden ich bin
auch jetzt an der stelle wo du gerade
bist glaube ich weil ich einfach mal
wieder schulmäßig der lange sprint ist
einfach so eine eklige leiterrunde ja
genau die diesmal hinter war eigentlich
muss man immer nach links und nach
rechts zu rücken
nur ich gegen rückwärtig g darunter die
leute ran
jetzt gehe ich hier jetzt wieder runter
du wirst auch im richtigen moment rüber
das leid ich bin auch bei der leiter war
sollte das take that [ __ ] komm ich
schlag dich nicht genug aber bitte vor
man müsste hier dem raum
ich habe echt keine ahnung gewusst 1
wphg listbroking medway wer is so much
jetzt nicht die kommen in einer hoch
muss dagegen sprechen und sagen
hochspringen nein natürlich habe ich
hier auch gerade so gemacht
es geht nicht du musst im genau
richtigen moment schon spät hoch
springen so spät wie geht auch gerne und
er perfekt aber na ja da bin ich hallo
wie geht es jetzt in der heißen schild
über der supporter fink konnte darunter
oder oder und hier drüben ist ja auch
gar nichts eigentlich außer diesen
komischer glaskasten und die truhe und
ich frage mich ja bin ich dumm
mein gott komme ich hab steuerung
gedrückt aussehen
ich frage mit machst du da oben wo ich
weiter ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
wieso hast du schon genommen
das war fröhlich management mensch hat
kann doch nicht sein
ich springe jetzt einfach mal probieren
glück aber ich weiß nicht wie es dann
weitergehe jetzt geschafft und dann ich
weiß ich bin jetzt hier drauf freunde
ich würd sagen wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
es weitergeht
schau dir nächste folge bekomme noch
nicht noch nicht auch nicht warte ich
muss auch noch mal auf deinen stand aber
ich bin jetzt hier aber was bringt denn
david zugesagt lockweiler für porto ja
irgendwie kann man da wohl kommt man da
wohl aus dem spiel heraus aber wie auch
immer ist ein video druckplatte hier ist
gar nichts kann man ja mal von oben
hinab schauen ob ich dachte ich jetzt
einfach mal die warten fm gar getötet
das ist eigentlich relativ sicher wieder
hochzukommen geht so aber ich bin auch
gerade wieder nach oben gegangen
egal ich musste sie folge werden wir
sind schon über 20 minuten meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen lassen
bewertung gar nächstes morgen bei ghom
wären wir weiter rum fällen und haut